there's a lot to talk about but I'm
gonna ask an ignorant question which you
might get mad at you playing against
Kobe right
he played with Kobe right if if you have
I'm sure even ask this but I just love
these questions if you had if you have
your all-star team well and you have a
choice between Kobe and Michael would
you choose oh that's good call I thought
you can say Kobe and LeBron with a [ __ ]
Kobe I've to me Mike's the greatest yeah
so I pick Mike because he was a better
teammate er no good that's not
necessarily true they're both [ __ ] I
know we never knew what kind of [ __ ]
Mike was until we got to see it on that
documentary but Kobe was the same way
come here cuz I'll try to I mean certain
guys I've heard I should try to fight
you do [ __ ] to kind of push your buttons
to motivate you or Michael to say well
Sheree did nobody ever push you well we
got in so you know we almost got in a
fight and that's how I ended up coming
to Lakers when I faked the ball in his
face so that we're not a keen nose on
Orlando ok you know cope was just a
tough minded [ __ ] mentally and
physically obviously skilled and gifted
but he always wanted to have that that
that mental you know advantage too so he
would do all kinds of grabbing elbow and
cheap shots kind of within the game
quote-unquote and I just wasn't having
it that day because I kept getting a
call for the past like we almost fought
haven't been and then he called me and
asked me if I want to come to the team
that followed us no that's a dog that I
mean he didn't know yeah yeah me and me
and Ron Artest both back scores that's
not a winner like I'm tired of
[ __ ] trying to beat me up so I
I talked to one of his teammates and I
well maybe I can say it Carlos Boozer
yeah sat next to him and Carlos told me
that Kobe like decided he called Carla
took three in the mornings like with
hello Kobe's like I don't want Jeremy
let on my team like he was he went but
he was he would yell to Jeremy because
and he said I'm not going on the court
with you because Jeremy was who's a
great player yeah I might be am i
speaking out of turn Carlos you know but
but it was just so obvious that Kobe was
just basically called Mo's I don't want
him on my team I don't think she be on
the team and Carlos is talking over Mike
right yeah but he would obsess over that
[ __ ] oh yeah people were obsessive yeah
super obsessive he was a like a
beautiful mind almost how much he
obsessed over being the best he can
absolutely be like he had tons of
god-given talent but that [ __ ]
work he was working out before the Sun
came up in the offseason every day I
used to go out to Orange County and work
out with him sometimes we're up on the
track before the Sun comes up waits for
hours we lift weight so hard the first
time I'm like brah the [ __ ] you expect
me to shoot now like my arms are like
jello but then I like that we're on the
court you know means that he was a he
was an animal you guys did the all the
smoke podcast with him I mean what
before he passed away no we released it
two weeks for you pass away we shot it
at the end of December okay but I would
see coab every other weekend because he
coached Gigi and I coached my twins so
all you know they're in the same circuit
she was 13 my kids are 10 where 10 at
the time so we're always girls and boys
similar age they're all named Trent not
two boys two boys so we're always at the
same tournament because there's always a
girl side in the boys side he would
always go out of his way heat me up like
hey if you guys didn't let me know what
time you play so I hit him with our
schedule and sometimes it'd be two hours
before we play he would sneak up and
with the security and check out my boys
team out and school come before after I
would go we've got his games when we
were done so I would see him pretty much
every other week I think 90% of the game
is mental first and foremost but when
you get Talent a lot of it like Kobe was
god-given talent I forgot he won a slam
dunk contest you're talking about yeah
Katie was god-given talent LeBron those
guys had a god-given talent but
god-given talent only get you so far you
have to apply that work ethic and that's
what makes good guys great you know I
mean cuz Kobe was a sicko Mike was a
sicko you know these guys that are great
are sick mentally from a standpoint of
they're gonna do anything it takes like
I loved basketball but when I work with
Kobe I worked at a different level
you know you mean like I always wanted
to work hard and I thought I was always
working hard but when I saw his
preparation and what he went through
thinking day after day night after night
rep after rep was like them I didn't do
as much during my career to be as you
know beat up cuz I didn't know his well
you don't pay the price right like I'm
sure you know and Michael Jordan talks
about this too like he was around as far
as a dad he wasn't there man yeah he was
he would his job was to be the best back
that comes a heavy toll man might miss
out on birthdays what to me III enjoyed
the ride you know what I mean I think
sometimes and I can't speak for a
superstar but I want to enjoy the ride I
don't want to be so locked into
something that I'm missing out on my
kids that I'm missing out on living that
I'm missing out on experiences with love
like I don't want to some end this is
not anyone in particular but some guys
get so sick on being the greatest that
that takes a lot away from their that
being normal you know being human having
fun having these regular interactions
and I just I wanted to enjoy the process
the Nano gamer I worked my ass off you
can never you watch one of my games you
know I played as hard as I could every
time I practice as hard as I thought
every time but I definitely enjoyed the
ride yeah you know what I mean and uh
and you you have you have Kobe over
LeBron as I do I think the broad can
pass him to be honest it to me it's Mike
Kobe Bron and I think bran can pass them
with another win Bron Bron it's not a
sicko like that no he's a different kind
of super we've never seen know what
LeBron is a Magic Johnson s yeah you
know I mean but just what bigger and
more athletic but just a different kind
of star where there's still the charisma
and the fun and the cool factor and all
that kind of stuff
he might be physically the greatest
athlete to ever step on the court I
wouldn't doubt that I mean all around
the zoo Boozer was saying I'm same size
and he said he's you understand his
speed oh yeah yeah that's that extra
speed that's so crazy
look how like being a draft them yeah
without ever playing a Davis right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]